and colors and middles hello everybody
my name is markiplier and welcome to
blank dream a brand new RPG maker horror
game that just came out literally a few
days ago and it's been a while since
I've played an RPG maker game especially
a horror one thinking back it was a
boring life I wouldn't say it was
entirely devoid of enjoyment but if you
asked whether I'd live the same life
again I'd absolutely refuse without a
doubt in fact if I had to say I've come
to hate it all I wish my life had never
even existed Oh more or less give or
take wishy-washy on that subject and so
I
Mashiro soui never having a seventeenth
birthday
threw myself into this lake oh okay oh
speaking of which this good prog in to
cover dark subjects like many of these
RPG maker horror games do hello you're
adorable
where is this what wasn't I just okay
right as the girl regained consciousness
she realized she didn't remember who she
was well that's awfully convenient for
the story all right what do we get here
okay I'll save not that there's any real
need to okay I can sprint which might
mean that I'm gonna be chased down the
road hello the mirror shows no
reflection I'm a vampire
oh okay I thought that was gonna be more
hello Wow oh hi the girl sees herself in
the mirror yeah talk to her hello me hi
what the hell's happening was your hello
I am you and you are me it's a mirror
obvious right did oh I've lost my
memories right don't worry me I know how
to get them back what does this girl
think she is me only on me only I know
what me em say to me do okay now look
into the eyes of your reflection no ah I
don't think so
who said you could look away oh did I
not have a choice in the matter okay
this is a bizarre start a familiar place
appeared before the girls eyes okay
hello hi teddy bear the teddy bear
stares with round eyes the girl felt
that this bear was very important to her
probably because you're a bear for my
bear me am my bear the girl felt an
unconscious urge to sleep here as one
more looking at a bed and nothing else
nothing else at all
a familiar dresser the girl felt makeup
wasn't worth the effort a school bag
rests on the desk a girl took a note the
girl took a notebook from it kakou
I can't read that Academy class one two
Mashiro soui her picture is on the cover
a familiar computer the girl
unconsciously went to powered on but
stopped hmm a lot of unconscious actions
going on here consciously the closet is
packed with black clothes with frills
the girl felt like she'd wear like to
wear the clothes like this the cabinet
is full of accessories the girl felt
that they all matched her taste well I
wonder why all of this familiar
familiarity is happening right here and
not my room of me in that am i I it
won't open
well why not look at everything huh oh
we're all got a nice wash you got a nice
why does she go to now why does me um me
got a knife
maybe I oh okay I got I got I got I got
it take not me the teddy bears right
there
why would I do that that's not a choice
that I'm all right fine the curl plunged
her knife into her hand done dude
follow me okay the girl came to again
standing before the mirror good good for
me though she still felt a vigorous
feeling in her hands there was no trace
of a knife wound welcome back how did it
feel killing yourself in the mirror
what's with that look you got a problem
come on I taught you how to get your
memories back
huh Mashiro is soui 16 i drowned myself
in the lake see only partial but you
remembered you remembered your name and
how you died look for the mirrors in
this world and then break them all
across this world are mirrors with your
reflection they reflect your memories
and you see how to break them right just
finish yourself off in the mirror oh oh
is that all oh oh break the mirrors
you'll get back your memories and at the
same time grant your wish once you break
all your mirrors you'll have it all back
and you can realize your wish that's the
way it works what's my wish you said if
you had the beginning of this game you
said a fan you had one wish you would be
to not live your life over again my wish
got it don't just look you have to break
them that's what's granting your wish
and Tails why is that you ask
remember that party yourself now find
the mirrors okay thanks me I'm just
gonna go take me off to me land and go
over this discover myself I don't
remember why I came to that but I
remember that strong wish I had to make
oh oh God that was the wish holy crap
is it dark dark game to make it so my
life never even existed yeah yeah just
as mashiro regained a piece of her
memory she felt as if she'd lost
something important yeah yeah how about
that yeah how about all that ah this is
some dark stuff this is like no joke
darkness oh good where are we now what
sort of weird bizarre dream world who is
that why is that where is this huh you
new here maybe whoa I picked one heck of
a moan to be here suspect huh huh oh I
just gave her a shifty look I guess oh
sorry sorry
Here I am getting all excited you just
came to this world right so I bet you're
confused by sure me I'm I'm you I'm sure
you can't even remember your name but
don't fret everyone's like that at first
I'm sure oh oh that's very polite of
wait you do you know your name that's
weird it took me so long for me to
remember my name who kick who cares
about you where is this this is known as
the mirror world it seems to be a world
for souls with strong wishes or
attachments I think it's one of these
places between life in the afterlife
maybe I just found myself here one day
so I can't tell you anything concrete
souls with strong wishes the weird thing
is while I remember having died with
some strong wish I can't actually
remember that wish you have any ideas
sure sex appeal I remember my wish you
remember your wish did you know how to
grant it
hold up Monsieur how blessed are you
gosh the world's not even fair in death
well anyway if you're gonna walk around
here be careful the evil spirits
wandering here because they'll be
jealous of a soul who can grant their
wish no doubt
great so how do I have to worry about oh
I was told that this game actually does
have quite a few jump scares and like
some chase scenes in it so I am kind of
eager to get to that because like the
first realm of death no life can live
with before a distorted wheel thanks for
that ancient proverb I'm so glad I have
that knowledge in my brain but I always
compare all the horror games that I
played to the witch's house which is
like it spoiled me because that was the
first one I ever did realm of greenery
let that meeting be a light of hope and
I spoiled it because I played that first
and then everything never lived up to
that realm of love now warm dead
illusion
uh did some pie besmirched you realm a
blood bathe in it if you wish and go ad
well why not I'll see what the Roman of
the realm of the ho okay nevermind I
didn't want to do that anyway thanks so
okay so I need to get keys to be able to
open these up I'm guessing it seems
unopenable
to the point that it could be mistaken
for an oddly design wall but I didn't
mistake it I knew realm of spirits on
the wind sounds tragedies end and
beginning ok so there's got to be a door
that can be opened first realm of beauty
for whom does the brush dance bronze
doors locked
what are these locked poopy alright fine
here AHA here we go ooh decorative axes
why not I'll take an axe sure I'd love
to have an axe can I take that okay
alright :
decorative swords accept blood whoa whoa
squishy squishy under defeat seized am i
turning into schmegle here constantly
targeting myself being all weird and
whatnot okay Oh nacio The Watchmen is a
fool who can only judge by number can't
he at least tell the real thing from a
fake this is fake blood or is it real
blood what should I fear here oh hi
the stone statue quietly lose oh I need
to I know oh I kind of want to find out
what happens if I go hard in PO no the
water job is a girl thing no gonna
happen Oh
dead end no kidding I'm dead at the end
me I'm dead at me body is dead at the me
em and I knew that was gonna happen I I
had every faith that that was I knew
what to do I just wanted to see what
would happen if I didn't okay so you
can't tell the difference between
faking the real thing so I need to put a
decorative axe back in there and
apparently I sell the knife from when I
stabbed myself in the throat okie dokie
thank you thank you very glad that that
happened in the way that it did okay so
that's all for the first part you're uh
oh yeah I I really do wonder if this
games going to be really really good cuz
I mean I I love I love these indie
horror games way I'll I'll keep this
short
thank you all so much for watching let
me know what you think of this one in
the comments down below
and I really hope you enjoyed it because
this seems like it's going to be a very
very very interesting playthrough to get
through so thank you again everybody and
as always I will see you in the next
video
Jackie changed after she got